Britain at a standstill a million
working days lost to strikes with more
to come
Railway workers but also nurses postal
workers and Airport staff
they're fighting for higher wages at a
time when inflation is ravaging their
paychecks
and the Fallout is being felt far and
wide
office workers usually come flooding
into this coffee shop
but the owner is now feeling the grind
he's serving half as many customers as
he did last week and is worried about
the future unfortunately really really
quiet so this week we've sort of planned
ahead and we've actually had to reduce
staff hours just so we can sort of
reduce our overall cost and it's
Christmas we should be getting busier
but actually we're getting quieter
with the government refusing to offer
inflation matched pay Rises there's no
sense of a resolution to these disputes
just yet
with the strikes rolling in City Center
businesses like these are having to
change the way they do business
some are reconsidering their Futures
altogether
the government says that higher pay
Rises are unaffordable and could lead to
an inflationary spiral
union bosses say workers shouldn't be
made to pay the price the offer of four
percent for this year and four percent
next year without even considering the
two and three years that we've missed
out on Pay we'll never be acceptable to
us so we need to get around the table
and negotiate an improvement and
hopefully we can do that in the next
period and the government has got to
facilitate that
holding firm in a fight that is partly
being waged in the court of public
opinion I agree with their right to
protest let's put it like that if I was
still working it might be a slightly
different scenario
I understand I stand with them I don't
like it because it affects me but
it's fair play so yeah
with more strike action on a this war is
far from over
for now the government is holding its
nerve hoping perhaps that support for
the strikers will Wayne
Sky News in Birmingham